[Applaudissements]
c'est beau
j'aime bien rasé au change tu as raison
mais si aujourd'hui je veux dire le
monde de la coiffure échanges ont alors
qu'il fait
[Applaudissements]
j'aime beaucoup les français allait bien
ça vous fait rire à moi je mets ça frère
on dirait que je vais sortir les
poubelles mais ses frais non mais sans
déconner c'est fou ça jouait les deux là
et regardez on est rodés à la vraiment
j'avoue j'en ai pas dans la même voie
bah il est magnifique il en fait on en
discute et parapublic comment tu
arriveras un corps pareil des abdos et
tout c'est hallucinant il est vraiment
très très bon mais cette nouvelle
coiffure la sgim en mode pistes de ski
c'est l'univers manga avant de le
coiffer vous montrer son forfait
[Rires]
voilà c'est quand il attendait le bus à
ses soldats était comme ça on entend le
son mythe
je vais vous oblitéré c'est parti
regarde c'est qu'il est là et il attend
le bus pour rentrer à la maison de
retraite mais mes jambes me parle pas ça
parce que ouais ouais ouais vous vouliez
un beau gosse pour la journée des câlins
il y en avait pas sur le plateau
donc on à faire l'appel et il n'y a un
garçon que j'aime beaucoup
un ami qui est venu le voilà
j'avais un cas doit faire vous arrivez à
un vrai cadeau pour vous attendez
l'arbre et cadeaux pour aulas
ce qu'ils font